Hello and welcome.
Today's
today's episode, we're taking a look at Fleet
and k c s by Rancher Labs. You
can't laugh at me in the first ten
seconds of that. Sorry. I
was already abused by the intro and then
the error message appearing
there.
Yeah.
I I really like that when I first
did it and I'm kinda like, I'm getting
really bored of it, but I have seen
it every day many times. Anyway, we're joined
by Bastian today from Rancher. We're gonna be
taking a look at Fleet k three s.
We're gonna be spaying up Kubernetes clusters and
having a bit of fun and seeing what
these tools provide to this common workflow.
And hopefully, make all of our lives a
little bit easier.
So hello, Bastian. How are you? Very good.
And thanks for the invitation. It's great to
be here. Yeah. I'm really excited for today.
So before we pop over to Bastian,
I have had some issues with audio lately.
So if anyone's watching live and I can
see a few of you now, please just
comment and tell me if my my levels
are too low or too high. Because yesterday,
someone informed me my levels were too low,
an error in five minutes into the stream.
So let's not make that mistake again.
Now for now, what we're gonna do is,
Bastian, would you like to share your screen
and just give us a quick introduction to
the tools we're gonna be playing with today.
Certainly.
Awesome. Okay.
I can't see any you anymore. Am I
sharing now? You are. Your slides are up.
We're on the side. Perfect. Great.
So
what we wanna look at today is how
you can manage multiple Kubernetes clusters running everywhere
up to thousands of them
with k three s Rancher and the project
we called Fleet that is gonna be introduced
in Rancher two dot five, which is scheduled
to be released next week.
And just to kick off off kick us
off, I wanna quickly talk, like, five minutes
or so why you actually would want to
do this and how this all ties in
together.
One of the nice things about Kubernetes is
that it's a common compute platform that you
can use everywhere across any infrastructure.
So you cannot only use Kubernetes to run
it somewhere in the cloud or in your
data center,
like, with one, two, three, four clusters
to,
yeah, power your websites
and your APIs.
You can also use it anywhere else from
your development laptop to edge use cases where
you run Kubernetes in factories,
in
shops,
windmills,
in five g towers,
wherever you have something where software is running.
And as a developer or a DevOps person,
the huge benefit you have from that is
that across all these different infrastructures where you
wanna deploy applications
and software too, you have a common API
to orchestrate all these deployments. You have a
common API to care about backup and recovery,
auto scaling, networking,
service discovery,
role based access control,
low balancing, and so on.
And all the differences
of all these different environments and infrastructures are
evened out, and they'll all look the same
for you.
Still, from an operational point of view, you
still have the challenge that you actually have
to manage all these Kubernetes environments
on all these different infrastructures.
And
whoever
all of you who maybe tried to set
up Kubernetes on their own at some point
in time probably discovered
that it's kind of complex to do.
Kubernetes consists of multiple different micro services that
all talk with each other. You have to
manage then each the d historic mechanism
in a highly available way that also means
more than one instance. You have to care
about certificates
and networking
and persistent storage.
And then even just orchestrating all the different
components of Kubernetes and making sure that they
are configured in a consistent way and can
communicate with each other is challenging.
And then, of course, you also have to
upgrade Kubernetes at some point in time
that can even make it more complex.
To make this easier and especially
in
these use cases where you wanna have hundreds
or thousands of clusters on all your different
edge devices,
at Rancher, we created a Kubernetes distribution called
k three
It's basically a Kubernetes, and it's also completely
standard compliant.
It is certified to be a standard compliant
Kubernetes,
so everything that works with Kubernetes can run-in
k three s.
But the difference is that all the different
components are bundled together in a single binary.
That means all the Kubernetes microservice
the services are now one binary,
and it also includes either for a single
node use case, an embedded SQLite database for
storage,
or for an use case, an embedded ETCD
storage.
It also directly bundles a container runtime, so
you don't need to have docker installed somewhere
or container. It bundles a c and I
plug in, DNS service, ingress controller, everything you
need to directly get started.
And because it's also all bundled in one
binary, the whole memory footprint of running k
three s is a lot lower than when
you run all the single microservices.
So, usually, you can get by with less
than 512 megabytes of RAM for
server, k three s server, and with less
than 200 megabytes of RAM for a worker
agent.
And this also makes it a very good
tool to run-in edge scenarios
where not only you have tons of clusters,
but also these clusters are limited in computer
sources that you have available.
And, of course, being a single binary deployments
are also very fast and very easy.
So that can solve actually running Kubernetes
on all of these edge devices
and all of these
small
micro devices. Ah, a good point is also
k three s also runs on ARM. So
if you have a Raspberry Pi, it also
works perfectly.
But still, you have thousands of clusters, and
somehow you have to deploy them, you have
to provision them, you have to do backups
and recovery of them, you have to monitor
them,
and also
you have to roll out authentication policies and
so on.
Of course, you can write your own Terraform
scripts, Ansible playbooks,
puppet modules, or whatever for that.
Or and that where Rancher comes in,
you can use the Rancher management server for
this.
With Rancher, you have a central management server
from which you can provision and manage
up to thousands of Kubernetes clusters on all
the different environments and infrastructures.
And then you have a central place to
not only provision them and upgrade them, but
also to set up authentication,
security policies,
monitoring,
and so on.
So
so just like a rough graph,
what we are gonna set up in the
next hour or so is we are gonna
set up Rancher.
Rancher is actually also just a workload that
runs in Kubernetes.
And from there, we are gonna create multiple
clusters. And, of course, they are all on
some VMs, but they could be running on
any kind of edge infrastructure
with different sizings and different
size of nodes, join them to Rancher, and
then we can manage all these clusters from
there.
So that solves managing clusters,
but still we have another challenge.
We also if we have thousands of clusters,
it's actually not trivial to deploy our our
our workloads or applications or software to these
clusters.
Of course, we can write script for that
scripts for that, and it's
a lot easier because we have a common
API to do these deployments.
But if you're imagining a script that deploys
to 1,000 Kubernetes clusters,
first of all, it probably will take quite
a long time. You have a scalability issue.
Then you also may have a connectivity and
fault tolerance issue because not every one of
your edge clusters on a windmill, for example,
will be available when you wanna deploy something.
You have to then care for that and
handle all these different problems.
And
we thought, okay. Since edge and these edge
use cases are very important, a lot of
our customers are going into this direction. Let's
make this easy as well. And there is
their fleet comes in.
Fleet is,
first of all, a standalone project, but it's
gonna be fully integrated into Rancher two dot
five.
And what it allows is to do multi
cluster GitOps deployment on scale.
The way it will work is you have
here down here all your clusters that you
attach to Rancher.
So Rancher would be this year, which also
directly includes Fleet.
You can organize your clusters in groups and
use labels to tag them, and then you
can
tell
with a GitOps approach, hey, Rancher and Fleet.
Here are my applications, and these applications are
called bundles
in Fleet.
And I wanna deploy this bundle with my
applications and helm charts or Kubernetes YAML files
or customized files
to these groups of clusters.
And you just do one API call to
set this up. And then these clusters down
here, they will pull the information asynchronously
and update themselves.
So you have a more scalable and more
fault tolerant solution.
And if one of the clusters currently is
offline, as soon as it comes online, it
will connect to the manager again and pull
down the new information what it should be
running.
So, yeah, that's
was my short introduction. Let's maybe then get
into actually setting this up and doing this.
Or do you have questions already so far?
Okay. Let's see what we have. So we
have a Hello Bastion from Chandrika.
We
have a nice wave from Siam. Nice to
see you again, Siam.
Very good. Who also has a little compliment
there for you. Fleet is awesome. He has
been Also, we're looking forward to get some
feedback then
about it. Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, and I think is that a question?
Alright. Let me just pop that up. So
they're saying that on a single Raspberry Pi
at home, they're running Docker and Cortina. They
have seen k three s, but wasn't sure
whether there were enough benefits
to run on a device. It depends on
how much RAM you have. So Kubernetes and
also k three s needs some of it.
You have probably a benefit if you have
multiple of the Raspberry Pi's. If you have
just one,
then you can also just do docker run
and Kubernetes doesn't give you that much benefit
besides playing around with it and maybe getting
used to Kubernetes.
But
it also depends on the Raspberry Pi. If
it's a one gig gram Raspberry Pi, it's
probably still very limited what you can do,
and you waste too much waste too much
memory for it. If you if it's a
larger four gig one or so, then it's
different.
Yeah. I think that's that's good advice across
the board. If you've got a single node,
you probably don't need to be running Kubernetes
or anything like that. The difference is if
you have 1,000 of these single node clusters,
then it could be interesting again.
Yeah. That's a good point. Yeah. I keep,
you know, Rancher at the management platform for
all those clusters. It's cool. So let me
share my screen now and show you where
we're at. So this is the the hands
on portion there. So in order to do
that, we have to provision a little bit
of hardware.
So through packet, I have provisioned as Rancher
one, two, three, four, and five. These are
all Ubuntu 20 o four machines.
All
x 86 m d 60 fours. Good to
go.
Now depending on time constraints and how we
can run today, I've added in a couple
of extra machines that we can maybe try
and take a look at. I added a
CentOS eight box and I have added an
ARM machine as well. So we can maybe
see that management playing across
the disparate clusters.
So the first step
is
installation,
I guess. Should I just pick the first
box SSHN
and then get started, or would you recommend
something else? Yeah. Let's just pick the Rancher
one box and install a small k three
s cluster on it and install Rancher on
it.
This is, of course, not a highly available
installation. Normally, you would need, like, three nodes
for this, but we are just playing around.
And the process of setting this up highly
available is very similar. What you mean playing
around? That's that's his prod for me. That's
okay.
This cluster is stuck in a row forever.
Okay.
Alright. I am on Rancher one. I do
have some documentation here as well. So this
is the k c s docs. Is this
where I start?
Yeah. You can either start with this one
or the installing Rancher one. It has the
same commands to set up a k three
s cluster.
And that's
This one. This one here. Okay. So we
can probably skip
the first
step on the left side. There are, like,
sub pages on that. So we set up
already the infrastructure. So the first thing we
do now is set up a Kubernetes cluster.
And this is a single node installation we're
doing. Correct? Yes.
And then we already have to adapt the
first command a bit because we are doing
a single node installation with just the embedded
SQLite database.
We don't need to
point it to a MySQL database for storage.
So one of the nice things also about
k three s is that you can point
it not only to the etcd
or to
to an embedded ETCD or to an embedded
SQLite, but also to external SQL databases for
storage.
Especially, a cloud provider that could be interesting.
Instead of having to run your own ETCD,
you can just fire up an Aurora or
something like that and point then k three
s to it when you set.
Nice. I like that. That flexibility to pick
the the back end store is pretty cool.
So you're saying all I need is this
curl s h server and then we're maybe
gonna add something to that?
For now, I would say we use the
default
version so we can
yeah. That should be fine.
Alright.
Yeah. So we removed the data sorting. So
that means that it's using by default an
embedded SQLite.
And what it's doing now, it's basically downloading
what the script is doing. It's seeing, okay,
which operating system are you running on, downloading
the correct binary. In this case,
Linux m d 64
binary,
then setting up some swim links for kubectl
and so on.
It creates a script to uninstall case regs
again, in this case, because we're in a
bundle sets of a system d service.
Hey. Cool. I mean Yep. So that's
what was this? Like, twenty seconds, thirty seconds
to set up a Kubernetes cluster?
Yeah. I thought we were gonna have to,
like, you know, make a cup of tea,
have a better chat back and forward. Right
away, I've got, like you said, under thirty
seconds, I'm typing cube control get nodes, and
it's telling me that my cluster is healthy.
That's pretty cool. I like that.
Maybe you can run h top. We can
have a look at bit of the memory
consumption. That could be interesting.
We're
barely tackling this thing.
Yeah.
So
We got 1.3 gig of memory of 62
being used. Maybe I over provisioned this cluster
a little bit. There's probably also bit of
bit of other stuff running on this. Yeah.
Well, this is really beefy box. Okay. Nice.
Yeah. We can we can maybe also have
a look at the
pots that are running in.
Yeah. Maybe in all namespaces,
and there you can see it already installs,
coordinates,
and traffic as an English controller, metrics server,
some local pass provision for local storage volume.
You, of course, you can also switch this
all out. If you don't like traffic, you
can say on installation, disable traffic, and then
roll your own English controller. It's a bit
for convenience that it's there. And is that
true for the CNI implementation,
or do I just get flannel and
You get by default, you get flannel, but
you can also say, I want don't don't
wanna use flannel and then install your own
CNI plugin
to install anything else. Because in the end,
it is standard Kubernetes.
Okay. Nice. So we have
we have our first k c s cluster.
Okay.
Then what we can use this one for
is then to yeah. We have k three
s running.
So just out of curiosity, why is this
prefix, this k c s? Kubectl is not
actually not installed. It's also kubectl is also
bundled in k three s in the binary,
and that's just like a
some link for this. Alright. So if I
run should be a symlink to
to the k three s binary.
Alright. Cool. Okay. So So and you can
also say k three s k three s
three s, and that will be the same
thing.
Always like to run the command. Okay.
Alright. Okay. So it's all embedded in a
single binary. Yep. And then the
cubes the cube control I actually have on
my machine is really just a wrapper or
something around this thing or link to it.
You can also use any of your own
cube procedures just like to make it easier
to use. Yeah. That makes sense to me.
So is there a next step then to
to install Rancher?
Yes. So you can see the next one
would be this
this
location where it actually wrote the cube config.
You could either download this
or we can use just directly use cube
CTL
on this box
however you want.
Susan?
This is a cube config? So I'm not
No. This is just a normal cube config.
Yeah. Yeah. Maybe don't show the total certificate
in there. Yeah. Yeah.
Alright. So let's get like this. Yeah. So
maybe let's use this box tool just because
we don't do we're not gonna use much
cube CTL stuff on the in this cluster
anyways.
So the next step would be then to
install Rancher.
Alright. Next.
Let's see.
And Rancher is used to install Helm, so
we probably need Helm need to install Helm
on this box. If you haven't
you can, I guess, use it use Snap
also to install it?
Okay. Let me just check. Yeah. We're not
gonna have Helm. Do I have Snap?
Nope. Let's just grab the Helm. Okay. And
then we have to it's just download the
binary, I guess.
I'm sure there's a curl bash here. I
can just yeah. There we go. Yeah.
X.
Get help. Get help. Okay.
So what we're saying is we can add
the Rancher
Helm repository,
and then we've got
oh, we need a namespace.
Got it?
Okay. Now we have to make one decision
because Rancher is
a sensitive workload
because you can manage Kubernetes clusters through it.
So you need a TLS certificate.
There are three options. Either
you provide your own certificate in a Kubernetes
secret. If you have your own CA or
you bought an expensive certificate, you can use
that.
We could use let's encrypt for it, or
we can just say, let's make it easy
and let Rancher
generate
a self signed certificate.
And for this for both let's encrypt and
self signed certificate, Rancher uses cert manager. So
we would need to use in source cert
manager.
Alright. So
that's going, create the names. I can just
copy all of the comments. So
I
think, yeah, it should be copyable.
Yeah. Yeah. It'll be it'll be fine. Okay.
Is that the last
Yeah.
We have to want do one thing. Of
course, the Helm binary
doesn't understand
the
the this symlink to k three s cube
config, so you have to export the cube
config.
Okay. So that's the export cube config equals
slash Rancher?
No. Yeah. ETC Rancher Case3SCase3SYamo.
Yeah.
And then also the Helm CLI
knows now.
Perfect. Okay.
So I think we have to wait now
until swap manager has started because it has
this nice webhook.
Okay. We don't have
k.
I mean usually have locally. It's not, of
course, you don't have this on VM. Yep.
Exactly. Already there. Yep. I can either make
that table 14,000 times over the next fifteen
minutes or whatever or just alias it now.
So Yep.
Yeah. Why I said we have to wait
is because this webhook needs to be started.
Otherwise, the creation of the certificate will fail
because Kubernetes will directly try to
call this webhook wherever a certificate is created,
and the Rancher Helm chart will directly create
a certificate.
Okay.
So next is then we have to install
Rancher.
And, basically, that's the command, but we have
to modify it a bit because we want
to
install the
newest
two dot five release candidate
to it.
So maybe if you Yep. Go to text
editor somewhere,
that makes it probably easiest.
Hey. Let's just quickly Perfect.
I'm assuming
I just copy this and change the number.
Yep. No? Yep. Correct.
I like it when things are intuitive.
So the newest one will be 250DashRC3.
And let's hope that RC 3 will work.
I have only tested r C 2 R
C 2 yesterday.
And the second thing is we have to
change the host name. Yeah.
And since
probably we
yeah. It would be a bit too much
to create now DNS entry. We could use
this zip.io magic DNS.
Do you know that?
Is that the IP address followed by
this?
Yeah. Correct.
So
Oh, I think actually from Basecamp, the service,
and you
that basically will resolve everything
to this IP address. And maybe add Rancher
in front of it, like rancher. And then
because
we may wanna have more than one.
That's great. You'll actually we're already getting the
traffic for a four page. Because yeah. Yeah.
Because English controller is there, and the default
by default, the case is English controller just
listens on port eighty and four four three
on the host network.
Okay. So what was your last comment there?
I've been putting do you think Let's maybe
do Rancher. And then the IP address just
to have, like, a nicer URL.
Yep.
Happy with that? That should be yeah. Looks
good.
If not, we can just fix
it and change.
Okay.
So
it's it's now starting, of course, three pots
because that's the default. Well, it doesn't matter.
They don't need some. We have a very
busy machine.
Otherwise, we could have set the replicas to
one or so in
this
one note installation.
So when this installs,
I'm assuming that we get some ingress set
up Yep. That's gonna make this resolve to
the the Rancher UI.
Correct.
So
it will
it will directly
one Rancher port is up and running.
And, yeah, the Rancher Helm chart will directly
set up an English resource as well as
the cert manager certificate
to get a self signed certificate for the
source. Is there a authentication by default, or
have I just given people access to a
Rancher UI?
No. There's authentication by default.
But you have to set up the set
up the admin password first.
One is faster
and set up one already.
We can but you can also reset the
admin password then.
Yeah.
First.
Okay. And we also gonna
use the
multiple cluster management thing
because we wanna manage multiple clusters.
Great.
And
we can just save this.
That can be useful if you have a
reverse proxy in front, it may not may
be able to detect the correct setting.
And we have a Rancher installation up and
running.
Awesome.
Yep. 2Dot5RC3.
The local cluster that is already in there
is the
cluster where Rancher is running in. So this
is also, by default, directly available. We could
also hide this if we don't want to
want users to see it.
It is a good practice to have Rancher
running in a single cluster just on its
own, just to separate the management
tool Rancher
as a control plane from
where you are running your workloads in in
different Kubernetes clusters
so that your workloads are not refer influencing
Rancher too much and that Rancher is not
influencing your workloads more importantly.
Okay.
So I'm liking this, a nice visual representation
of of my clusters and my individual cluster.
We just have another quick question there from
from Siam who's saying multiple management option is
not there in r c two. Is that
correct?
It's still there. I think it's just in
r c two. For some reason, someone removed
the that you can choose it when you
install it, and you directly go to the
multi management setup.
And you could not switch to the just
a single cluster management, which is new in
Rancher two five.
Awesome. But the multi cluster management is actually
what you see in Rancher two four already
or two three or two two. That should
this is what you're seeing now. This is
more new.
And what you saw before is then what
existing Rancher users should be familiar with.
Okay. So just to recap, I mean, there's
there's a lot that happened with that element
still there. We
have deployed the Rancher.
I mean, it's
is it just a UI? Rancher is just
a UI that allows me to manage,
integrate, explore my customers. There's no other components
to it. Is that have I got to
understand it correct? Yeah. It's a UI and
API and kind of like an operator, you
would say.
Okay. So Rancher did operators before operators were
cool.
Nice.
Okay.
So this is the cluster explorer.
I mean, besides just taking a look at
pods, jobs, all the other Kubernetes resource, Is
there anything
that particularly cool or important that you wanna
cover on that before we move on to
the Maybe go back to the cluster manager.
Upper upper right. Oh, there we go. Yeah.
So where you can see all your the
multiple clusters. And if you go back to
on the left upper upper left where low
where is local to global,
you can see that you can add clusters
there. Maybe if you click on it on
the upper right side, you can now then
now start to add clusters on any kind
of infrastructure.
And the cloud providers you see there are
just the ones that that are activated. It's
a plug in system. You can even add
more to it.
You can register
all the cloud provided managed solutions,
or you can install a new Kubernetes cluster
on existing node or just import an existing
Kubernetes cluster.
Directly, you've I'm not feeling the the packet
love here, Bastian.
In the end, it's Docker machine. So it's
also not something that we completely invented, and
I think there is a Packet Docker machine
driver. Is a Packet Docker machine driver. You
wanna edit?
Yeah. Yeah. I'm gonna get that. I'll work
on that next week for sure.
I think one of the things is for
all the supported ones, the usually, you also
have, like, a nice UI then.
If you
if you just use a plain Docker machine
driver, you probably just have input boxes in
the UI and not, like, drop downs or
stuff like that.
Okay. Nice.
Also, what
interesting there is that under if you click
on security in the top box
Yep. Yeah, and then authentication,
You can see that you can
configure all kinds of enterprise
authentication systems, some are based ones, active directory,
l dub, you name it.
And then you can get all your users
and groups imported for there so that these
users and groups can authenticate at Rancher.
But not only at Rancher, but also on
all connected Kubernetes clusters.
And then you can set up directly
centrally in Rancher,
granuly
all the roles that you wanna give people
globally in Rancher, but also within one cluster.
And these are then gonna be rolled out
as standard Kubernetes role based access control to
all attached clusters.
So is this managing the deployment of decks
across my Kubernetes cluster, or is it its
own mechanisms?
It's
it's own mechanism.
So in the end, every user will get
a token, a dedicated token. This token was
synchronized in every Kubernetes cluster,
and
it also can expire and everything. So it's
a token based authentication on Kubernetes level, and
these tokens are then managed by Rancher
and attached to this active directory users, for
example.
Okay. Nice. I like it. So I would
say let's add more clusters to it to
have some fun and deploy stuff for. Right?
Oh, yeah. So we do have another question
from my friend, Sam, here who's asking if
we're able to update the k c s
cluster from the UI.
Yeah. Let's let's go let's do this next
and install a bit older one. Right? I
would say. Yeah.
And
yeah.
Let's do
that.
So if you I would say let's add
two three clusters for now.
One single node cluster that can we can
run-in a slightly older version, and then we
can test the update.
And then maybe
also on three VMs, a highly variable cluster
to have to see how that looks like.
Okay. So the the process for them doing
this. Now do I go on to each
of these machines and provision k three s
and then add them to Rancher? Or do
or can Rancher do something with the IP
address, like, on provision?
Currently,
there's a way there is a way for
Rancher
to directly install Kubernetes cluster on these machines,
but
that would be an RKE cluster running on
Docker.
It's also standard Kubernetes, just a different distribution,
and it's using the upstream images. So there's
no modification at all.
The downside of it,
why I wanna go the k three s
way is k three s is much faster.
And with RKE, it's like five, six, seven
docker images. It needs to configure each d
and everything. It just takes longer.
Alright. So let's And there's no benefit to
it. So we first create currently
on the VMs, a k three s cluster,
and then we can import it into Rancher.
But then we can manage everything through Rancher
upgrades and so on.
Okay.
So maybe can I post
easiest as we is I just put the
command
instead of our private chat? Right? Then Yeah.
Go for it.
Just so that we can install k three
s in a slightly older version.
Alright. So this is the same k three
s command we used earlier,
only this time we are setting an environment
variable to specify an just an older version
so that we can
That we can upgrade it. Yeah. Got it.
And it's now using the newest one seventeen.
We could also specify the exact version if
we wanted to,
but
I'm always too lazy to do that.
I love this curl command that in twenty,
thirty seconds, I get a cluster. That's just
ridiculous.
Okay.
So we have a cluster now. And to
add a torrential, if you go back to
UI
Got it. And you click on add cluster,
you can now import register an existing cluster.
No.
Not on existing notes.
This
register an existing cluster above this and then
other cluster.
Got it. And then we can give it
a name.
We could now directly
add. If you have multiple users or groups,
you could directly give them permissions in this
cluster. Of course, you can also do this
later on.
And
maybe let's directly give this also a label
for late later on.
And maybe label
I don't know. Group also doesn't matter so
much. And then one
or Ubuntu. Yeah. Let's maybe Google Ubuntu. That's
great.
We can use this later on to fleet
to decide then, okay, deploy to all Ubuntu
clusters or deploy to all clusters.
Ah, nice. Okay. And
now we basically get a kubectl apply command
that we can execute. And we since it's
self signed, we have to use the one
below that because it is a self signed
certificate. Otherwise, kubectl will say invalid TLS certificate.
Got it. Okay. So
this is the same as this command only.
Yeah. Just that downloads the YAML with scroll
and then pipes us into kubectl apply.
Done.
K. Yeah. Once these pods are started,
they
should then also
build up the connection to Rancher.
Basically, what this is is it insults a
small agent into the cluster. And this is
also in every connected Kubernetes cluster. The only
Rancher specific thing that is not standard Kubernetes
is this one agent. And the job of
the agent is to connect to the API
and make it manageable.
And the rest is standard Kubernetes.
Yep. And now we have the second cluster
there, and maybe we can directly upgrade it.
Right?
I'll take your word for it. Yeah. So
can I click on this cluster?
Yep.
So first of all, maybe before we upgrade
it, can you just click on the cube
config file
there?
This gives you you're gonna hit on everything
afterwards. Otherwise, it will show you a token.
Okay. Then let's not show it.
This is also the way how you get
now a cube config
with
user token that is dedicated to the user
you are logged in into Rancher. So if
you have had your active directory
connected,
you would now have active directory based authentication
at this cluster.
So that's cool. Really cool.
But
Well I mean, was fast enough.
Oh, people can pause it, I'm sure. So
Yeah. It's well, whatever. But I'll turn it
just don't go mining crypto for the next
half hour.
Okay.
We can now also
yeah. If you click on the context menu
with the three dots in the upper right
Got it. And click on edit.
And there you have a drop down with
the Kubernetes version. And, yeah, you can choose
any new one.
Click save.
With the concurrency, you could have also if
you have a multi cluster
multi node setup, configure
how many nodes should be updated in parallel.
If you have 50 worker notes, you probably
don't wanna go one by one, but
update several ones in parallel.
And it also can directly if a multi
node setup, then drain containers away before updating.
And I'm assuming because k three s is
bundled as a single binary, is that the
upgrade process is just pulling down a new
binary and then replacing the process. Yep. Like,
that's done. It's also done already.
Okay. So, I mean, I could run
SCS.
That doesn't show the version. Version. I
think it's just for
Of course. There we go. Oh, yeah. One
nineteen.
Our client and server. Alright. Nice. So it's
upgrade. Oh, of course. Yeah. It also this
is funded. It also directly up updates KubeCTL
on that note as well.
Yeah. So that was the single note setup.
Should we directly add an assert to assert
cluster to it?
Yes. Okay. So I grab this IP address.
And And I would say let's do it
slightly
differently
and set up
a highly available multi node cluster
and maybe also we see embedded SCD so
that we directly have
not only one control plane server node, but
multiple ones.
And is this where you tell me you're
gonna give me the command for that. Right?
Yes.
So
one you're on one on the first node
for this cluster,
this this embedded entity is only available in
one nineteen. So I directly specified one nineteen.
And to make it easier,
I directly specified
a token secret that we need the the
secret this token secret we need afterwards to
to connect all these notes together. It needs
to be the same in every command.
And
with this cluster in a variable, I'm basically
saying initialize
it's the cluster as well.
Okay.
And with this case, we have x x
server saying this should be a server node
and not an agent node.
Yeah.
But, basically, it's doing same thing, just one
nineteen with x d
included.
And is this still gonna take twenty to
thirty seconds? Or Yes.
And
the
second
command, we do the so we probably should
do a three node cluster because at city
needs forum. Right?
Okay. So we have two more nodes. So
that's good. Yep. So the we need the
IP
on the two other nodes, we definitely need
now now the IP address on of the
first server node.
And,
yeah, I also send you the command for
the other two notes.
Alright. Got it. So
And you have to change the 3 u
l then to the correct IP address.
That, I can just about manage.
So So this is pointing, basically, 6443
is the
port of the API server
so that it can connect to it correctly,
and it is all then authentication versus
very unsecured token.
Well, yeah. I was thinking that. I mean,
people could join this cluster just
by heading these IP.
Let's hope that they're not destroying our demo.
Right?
It'll be fine.
People are nice. Right? Yeah. So
well, we add this arm one. Would that
work?
That's the third part. Question
it.
Yeah. Let's try this maybe. I have never
had a
never did did a setup with
share with different CPU architectures in the control,
it should work actually.
I don't see what I'm trying to think
if there's any components that wouldn't run on
ARM, but I think it should be okay.
Yeah. I mean, it it I've seen the
URL change there. It was definitely done with
an ARM binaries.
So
let's So if you do QC to get
notes, you should see that there are no
yeah, two That one is just starting. The
other one is still starting the system d
service. So
yeah.
So it's not ready yet, but maybe it
just takes a couple seconds because it also
needs to install the c n I plug
in
or yep. Now it's ready.
Nice.
So we have now a three node Kubernetes
cluster
with one r we basically, what we have
now is three nodes, and all nodes have
all roads. So there are worker nodes, it's
a d, and master nodes or control plane
nodes.
Yeah. Every time I run this, I expect
to see a fourth node, but you know?
We could also add a fourth node to
it.
If that would be probably where we say,
hey. We just add a fourth worker node
to it if you want to. No. No.
I'll I'll let our audience add that force
code if they're feeling brave. So Okay.
Yeah. Then the next step would be also
to add this to Rancher the same way
we did before.
Okay. So I just pop back over to
global.
I add
cluster,
other cluster.
I give it a name. So this is
our cluster.
And I'll get this
a p j. And even though it's not
all Ubuntu, I just wanna grip that with
the previous one. Yeah. Yeah. That would be
nice that we can still connect it to
it. And it has some Ubuntu notes in
it. Right?
It does. Yeah. I think was it group
that I used, the key? I think it
was. I group. Yeah.
Alright. We grab the insecure
command,
and we run that. And
this is magically gonna show up again.
Pending.
Yep.
Okay.
Are we okay with two clusters to deploy
to them, or do you wanna add a
third cluster?
No. I I think that's good. You know,
we've got a single solo node one. We've
got the agents It it would be basically
the same.
And also the command to add additional worker
nodes,
so non control play nodes to k three
r s is basically also the same same
instead of saying
server, you say agent, right, in the command.
Okay. Cool. Well, that's important.
Yeah.
Maybe on this bigger cluster,
we
can see here in the UI that it
already shows you a bit of information about
what is kind of reserved as resources into
the cluster.
But maybe let's also activate the Rancher integrated
monitoring
to see a bit more metrics and dashboards.
And,
yeah, let's let's keep yeah. Let's keep it
at this because I I'm fairly con convinced
that this will run on ARM.
Yeah. We can just use the default.
It should be fine.
Sorry. I was getting ahead of myself there.
I'm just clicking buttons.
That's fine.
Maybe one interesting
thing is that we are it was Rancher
2 Five, and it mentions this at the
in the top that we are also provided
version two of all this monitoring integration that
is even more flexible.
But let's keep the v r v r
v one one because I'm not sure if
the version two of the monitoring that is
new
already works on ARM. It should probably, but
I'm not sure.
So this is the the new one. Right?
The new one is a new one. In
the end, it's it's using the premises operator.
Both of them do.
The new one is more flexible and more
in line with what is upstream.
But we can
yeah. Let's keep it to this. If you
go back to the cluster page, if you
click on cluster
yeah. Cluster. Okay.
That's not completely ready yet.
What does that's just deploying exports.
Right? Am I am I correct? Yeah. It's
deploying
Prometheus
and
here we go.
I think it may have scheduled something
on the ARM note that is doesn't have
an ARM image
app.
Yeah. It's some sort of operator, and it
is Can you try to re delete these
ports and hope that they are or maybe
let's let's cordon the ARM note for now.
Rancher,
tap in.
Yep. And to
delete
parts.
Long pasty window.
The kettle the
The namespace.
The namespace is kettle
well,
Prometheus
something.
Kettle system. No. It's not this one. Okay.
Kettle Prometheus. Yeah.
So I don't think I regret my my
poor choice of tabbing layout here. But No.
You can also go to the Rancher UI.
I think that was a a good point
to
have a look at the all these ports
in the Rancher UI, then it's oh, there
it's up.
So
you can see here now, you have now
a bit more metrics. And if you open
up this cluster metrics box
Where is that?
At the bottom of the screen. Yeah.
You can see it already starts pulling metrics
of all the different notes.
Of course, we take some time until all
the data's there, and you also have a
link everywhere to Grafana that gives you more
detailed dashboards.
And, of course, you can then extend this
and monitor your own applications if you add
an influx to be to it or so.
You can also scrape this with Prometheus
at your own dashboards to Grafana.
It's very flexible.
Yeah. Nice. Very cool. I like it. And
you get it set up with all the
defaults with a sensible set of alerts, sensible
dashboards for everything you need to discriminate to
do the click.
That is also quite nice.
Okay.
So I think
that's a really
it's
it's it's cool. I like this. You know,
we've got cluster management. Important that was if
I even provisioning the clusters themselves was an
absolute breeze. And we now have this single
pane of glass for lack of a better
term for working with my clusters.
As now, when we
look at Fleet and start deploying stuff? I
would say so. Or if you of course,
you can look at other things if you
want to first, but maybe Fleet would be
kind of nice.
Yeah. Let's let's get some work load running
on this.
Okay.
For that, you have to go to the
Explorer UI because that's where the fleet UI
is located. So click on Explorer, maybe on
the local cluster. I think it doesn't matter
even.
It doesn't matter.
You should go to both.
Click on cluster explorer on the top. It
goes all to the same UI in the
end. Yeah.
And if
you go now into the upper left corner
on the drop down there for our cluster
explorer
Yep.
And go to Fleet.
So this is the Fleet user interface.
And what you can see already
on the clusters,
As you would expect,
there are
two three clusters already registered, the local one,
and then the two ones we created then.
And by default,
it created
the
new clusters we added in the fleet default
workspace,
but we could add multiple workspaces and move
all clusters around and organize them to workspaces.
And if you go to cluster groups,
this is how you can group clusters together,
and there's already
one cluster group. Maybe we can add additional
group for our one to 20
clusters.
Alright. Let's see if I can work this
out.
That would be easy. Yeah. We're already in
the default workspace
and yeah.
Have been to 20 clusters.
The selector's
gonna be Yeah. The labels. Selector. Yep.
And, of course, we had connect we could
also give that labels if you wanted to,
but it's probably not necessary.
Labels all the way there. Yeah. And
then you should be if it works
can
you click on the group?
It's not there, is it? No. The group
is there, but the clusters are not registered.
Oh, that's oh, okay. That's just the workspace
default. Got it. In the workspace default, you
have the group there, but we have
zero clusters. Why is that? I probably just
messed up. So I'm gonna see Can you
go back to maybe
no. Go back to Fleet. We can also
directly edit it from there
and should see it.
But if I was if I were debugging
this on my own, like, the way I
was I guess I would have to go
check the labels that I added to my
cluster here. Yeah.
If I had oh, that was in the
edit menu, wasn't And
then here I added labels. Annotations
and the first, there are the annotations and
the labels.
So did I not add
Okay. We'll add it that. I think I
did, but maybe let's yeah. Let's go back
to the fleet interface.
There we can definitely edit.
Excuse me? Interesting. I would have expected that
this will work because I think I saw
you
doing this. So if you go to clusters
Yep. Got it. And then you click on,
for example,
one the cluster also. Yep. And you can
now go in the context menu, edit it.
But it has a label group Ubuntu 20.
There you can also see it.
Oh, yeah. I do see it. Oh, but
Did we do a typo?
Probably. I mean, whenever something goes wrong, it's
generally my fault. So
Okay.
Or did we do this in the?
So if I click on my cluster group
and edit as form
oh, my rule's not there. Okay.
Can you edit this as YAML?
Oh, no. It's the it's match labels.
So
k.
Can you go to back to cluster groups?
Maybe it's just worked and we were too
fast also. So this is all declarative. Right?
I mean, I could have this in a
get repository and apply it to my cluster
without ever touching the UI. That's pretty cool.
I like that. Yeah. It's all good based.
Can you refresh maybe?
Yeah.
It definitely worked yesterday.
Okay. Interesting.
Okay. Let's not use cluster groups then and
just go forward.
What we can now do is we can
so
to deploy something with Fleet, it is a
GitOps based approach. So you have all your
resources, your applications in Git repositories,
and we can now add a Git repository
to Fleet.
Basically, is we have to give it a
name,
the URL to the repository.
This is a
repository that I prepared.
And, I mean, I I didn't really speak
to you about it. I just gone ahead
and added some YAML to it. So it's
just straight up Kubernetes manifest fails to deploy
Telegraph and and FlexDB. Okay.
Yep. Looks good.
Then you could set up authentication
if we had not a public repository.
It is an either username based or SHK
based. You can set up the branch that
should be watched,
and then we can now add multiple pass
to it. And
Because I applied
every pass will be
will be a bundle
in
Right.
So if I do enter For every bundle,
it's kind of like in one application. And
don't do I think you have to remove
the leading slash.
In my test yesterday, it only works without
The example is wrong then. Yeah.
People are heavy at work, especially at the
UI. And maybe at a a second pass,
we could for the second application for to
it. I guess that that's important just to
remind people. We are running on a release
candidate version of 02/2005. So these little these
little things
are expected.
Okay. And then we can basically under deploy
to configure
which where this good repository should deploy to,
and you can choose your workspace.
And I think I know what happened with
the cluster group.
We added it to the wrong workspace.
Can
you maybe go open a new tab also
just to check?
And
can you delete this cluster group that we
added?
Yep.
And let's create a new one.
And in the workspace
yeah. You have to choose fleet default
because the clusters are in the workspace fleet
default and not in the workspace default.
If I just add my group
into 20 label and then hit create. Yeah.
Know we have
That's good.
So
we could say cluster group and yeah.
And this will then deploy should deploy this
to all clusters.
You can also click on the name, and
you should see the events popping in.
Maybe
we have to wait a bit or yep.
Now you see the
resources are being applied
in
the cluster.
Nice.
So if I pop over here,
pods
and watch,
And plug TV is running.
My telegraph is running.
My arm one failed. And that's annoying because
I checked that there was an arm in
the manifest.
Well,
but besides that,
my job is completed, which means I have
authentication.
So Is it maybe
I don't know if wrong version also
that we are using in the YAML or
So if I do Or can maybe just
try to debug it a bit and then
fix the error, push it to the repository,
and see it updating.
That will pass. So what I would normally
do is I could describe my my daemon
set here and check the image, but I
guess I can just use the UI now.
Right? Sure.
You if you go
back from the Fleet
UI,
you can choose no. You can either do
that. At the moment, they are both two
ways because we are in the phase of
transitioning to a more flexible UI.
So can go to the cluster explorer,
choose the correct cluster, like the cluster
that is correct, and then you can, for
example, go to stateful sets.
Mhmm.
Oh, daemon's daemon's set. Oh, daemon's sets. Sure.
Sorry. Yeah. Daemon's and go in there and
you see all your ports and events
and maybe click on the
trailing one.
So I think yes.
The Alpine one probably doesn't work on ARM.
Ah, that could be maybe we have to
use the non Alpine one. Right?
At telegraph
one
so one fourteen definitely has ARM.
Give that a second.
Yep. There's ARM 64,
but I'm assuming
maybe the Alpine one doesn't.
Let's let's just. Yeah. There we go. Yep.
It's okay.
So I But it's great that
Yeah. I was like, I I tested that
manifest. I know it's good.
So let's
take off the Alpine. So
I'm just gonna make some assumptions here. Please
feel free to correct me. If I just
push this to my GET repository,
is there a auto sync that runs or
do I need to configure that through Fleet?
Nope. Push should be fine.
That's your that's that's the whole goal of
it to
make this like a GitOps based approach to
manage.
Now we have two clusters. Imagine, again, you
have windmill park, and on every windmill, you
have
like, on a turbine, you have, like, a
small Kubernetes cluster and you have thousands of
them. You
wanna have such approach.
Alright. So I hope that works.
Because, actually, this is I had not tested
that.
Maybe you can
you should be able to follow it in
the Fleet UI.
Of course, it will also update here at
some point,
but maybe the fleet are out of sync,
and it should now start synchronizing.
Because it saw okay. There is a new
commit.
And
the daemon I also saw that the daemon
sets changed.
Okay.
Excuse me.
K.
Oh, there we go. Modified. Modified.
No longer out of sync. So if I
go to
cluster explorer,
daemon sets,
we have 303. It worked. So
that means I
oh, I'm not on my machine.
Let's
port forward.
Oh, I'm gonna need the kube config, aren't
I?
Yeah. You could just SCP it or pull
it.
Or you can download one.
If you go back to the cluster manager,
you could go on cube config file and
quickly copy it or
download it. I'm gonna shut this down in,
three seconds. Oh, go Not quick. Download link
if you wanted to have that. Okay.
Okay.
So call this
cube
config.
And if I
grab my terminal here okay. So we can
do export
cube config equals
cube config.
That's not the right directory.
Where did I save you to? Oh, it's
M Site Telegraph D S. Okay.
That environment variable should still work. So in
theory, I can run get notes.
Nice.
Can run
yeah.
I have my aliases now too. So get
pods,
port forward, and I wanna log in to
InboxDB.
I wanna see those metrics
working.
And also to just
reiterate,
you now have only the permissions that
you were assigned in Rancher. So the whole
if you had LDAP or active directory authentication,
that will be would be all now reflected.
Okay. Excellent.
I like the authentication stuff being made easy
because
I'm very bad for just letting that slide
for convenience. So Yeah.
There's one thing I need. So I create
a secret in this, and I can't remember
what the password is. So let's just decode
that. You can also just maybe
a trick go to the Rancher UI and
copy it from there.
Oh, nice.
If you go, for example, to projects and
namespaces this is one way.
And now
you have it in it was in in
the default namespace created?
Yes. You create in the default namespace. And
click on the project default.
Yeah. And then on the resources
in the top,
you have secrets.
And
yeah. There you have and then you can
just double click
on this,
or you can just copy it now from
there. I think if you copy it, you
have it in clear text.
With some sort of what? Voodoo?
Let's see.
No. That didn't work. No.
Okay.
Maybe then just click on the upper right
on edit.
Well, will the cluster screen will give me
a nicer view than you want? I don't
actually don't know. We can check.
But you can definitely
go to it and then click There we
go. Oh, yeah. It shows us in clear
text. Yay.
Okay.
I had explorer.
Ah, there we go.
Look at that.
Maybe?
There we go. Alright. Let's just drop that
down to five minutes.
I wonder why that's
slow coming down the wire. I guess it's
not important.
Alright. I have my metrics. Nice.
So that's
taken a GET repository
with my manifest, my applications in it, deployed
it to the cluster based on my
cluster group that we configured through labels.
I mean, I guess, my question is I
can just
add extra
if I added that label to my other
customers, that workload would just be shipped out
to them all. Right? Yeah. Sure. Maybe we
can even try this.
Let's maybe add a certain an additional cluster
and see that it's also rolled out there.
So maybe if you go to if you
go to cluster manager again, and you have
one we have left. Right?
I think.
So we oh, no. I think we deployed
to H E and Rancher 2. It's the
same labels there, didn't we?
So you wanted to see now that if
you added an additional cluster
to it, that it also deploys it on
there or
Yeah. So is Yep. I mean, it's it's
already done it. Like, both my both
my clusters are running Telegraph and then FlexDB.
I mean, if you added now an additional
cluster and also gave it this label so
that that actually met matches this
this cluster group, it also would Fleet would
directly add this new cluster to the cluster
group and also deploy it there.
If you want, we can demo that.
Yeah. Sure. So what's the what's what's step
on there? So we would add an additional
k three s cluster, create a new one.
We I think we have one VM left.
Right? Alright. We have Rancher five, which I
don't believe we're using it. Yep. So I
just SSH on there, execute our lovely little
curl command. Yep.
Let me just grab that from over here.
We can just use a default one. Right?
Yeah. Sure.
I mean, let's just stick one nineteen on
it.
And then to add a cluster, I come
to the UI.
I click cluster manager.
I click add cluster.
I'm getting the hang of this.
Global
at
see,
this is it's just too easy.
Yeah. Also, direct stop directly at the
the group label. Yeah. Open to 20.
We grab this this command here.
And then I'm gonna pop over here
and
we're now in a pending state. So what's
gonna happen here is that's gonna bring
this cluster under management by Rancher.
Fleet is gonna detect the label, add it
to our cluster group, and then deploy or
get ops workflow to the cluster. That's that's
that's the magic you're telling me about to
happen. Hopefully.
Alright. So I don't have access to cluster
explorer yet. It's still importing. Let's just give
that a few minutes.
Yep. Let's see what we have on the
comments.
So we got a tada from Jason. Yeah.
I was very happy that it worked too.
That was awesome.
John says the stream looked great. Thank you,
John. Appreciate it.
And Sam saying here comes the influx the
expert.
Yeah. Whenever you find them, let me know.
I don't know where that person is.
And we have our cluster. We have a
cluster explorer.
I'm excited to the human set already.
Yep. We've got our get ups here.
If I go back
is it there? It is.
Yep.
Too easy, man. Too easy.
Maybe I sent you another link in the
private chat that would be maybe nice to
just show the documentation page once for Fleet.
Let's do that.
Because what's also nice about it that
for these git repositories, you cannot only put
just standard Kubernetes YAML in there. It also
understands Helm chart. It understands customize.
And there is even, like, this fleet YAML
file that you can add to it to
make them customization based on cluster labels.
So you can say you have
you deploy this to the whole cluster group,
but on all clusters that are labeled
with something production,
you configure it slightly differently
to
add to also have these use cases. So
it's actually very powerful.
So if you scroll a bit down, you
can have a look at the fleet YAML,
you can see you can pass all kinds
of helm values in it, and then there
should be also
below this customization.
Yeah. These target customizations, you could say, okay.
For these targets, please use these overlays and
do different helm, values for it. Yeah.
For the whole bundle.
It's actually very very flexible.
And if you scroll up a bit, it's
also interesting.
You can also configure a rollout strategy for
all the clusters.
So this rollout strategy is not for the
deployments or so. It's actually how many clusters
should be updated in parallel and how many
should be max unavailable or something like this.
And unavailable means it's currently being updated.
So it's an actual a gradual rollout of
my workloads on a cluster basis. So roll
out to two of my clusters before I
send out to two all of my cluster.
Yep. And that works for
the modifications that I make to so when
I modify my Gelb thing, it's gonna test
it in one cluster then start rolling out.
Right? Yep.
Of course, what it's doing in the end,
it's doing helm upgrade, kubectl apply, or the
equivalence for this.
There is not something in that then that's
kind of like load testing,
but it's just checking that the applications are
coming up. But if you have proper
readiness probes and live disk probes, that would
be reflected.
It's pretty impressive. I gotta say, like Yep.
What's the
I mean, the golden question here is is
Fleet's pretty new. Right?
So
have I should I be rolling this out
to production? Do would you advise that we
just keep an eye on the project? I
mean, what what's the consensus on that at
the moment?
So it's gonna be generally available and under
enterprise support by us
with Rancher two dot five. So
the
two dot two five o release is
scheduled next week,
and then a reset is gonna be marked
as stable. So
that usually takes, like, two five one or
so until we say it's not the latest
release anymore, but one that we consider stable
and that also the community tested before.
And yep.
Then you can definitely
use it.
Awesome. So we have a a question here
from Jason. Jason is asking if there are
any hooks.
I'm assuming Jason is asking if there's, like,
a pre install, post install hook similar to
what Helm offers.
The Helm hooks definitely will work. So if
you use the Helm hooks in a Helm
chart, these are gonna be executed.
For non Helm resources,
that's actually a really good question.
Actually
okay.
Sayam says it's yes. It's possible. Okay. That's
all there are.
If you have a a link to any
documentation on that, Sayam, if you wanna drop
that in a chat, we'll pop that up.
Yep. So it sounds like that is possible,
Jason, and we'll try and get you more
information.
They have another question here.
So I'm Eric is asking Fleet without Rancher.
Is that possible?
Yes. So Fleet is a standalone project. You
can use it on your own.
Just for the Rancher Ads, it's like the
nice integration with the UI. So the UI
is not available as a standalone UI,
but then you could just use Rancher for
that. It is also open source. But if
you don't wanna use it, you can also
just use Fleet on your own in any
kind of Kubernetes clusters. So if I can
take any vanilla Kubernetes cluster, run the Fleet
controller, point it to my Git repositories, and
get that same GitOps workflow without
anything else. Yeah. You also quickly showed it
that in the end, everything that Rancher does
is just creating Kubernetes resources for Fleet. Right?
So can I just do get
They are in the local cluster? So in
the first Rancher cluster, you can see.
Oh, that was that was too many tabs
ago. Come on. Okay. Let's
jump back on that issue. Yeah.
So for Fleet, there are customer source definitions
for git repos and
everything. So can you could say kubectl
get, I guess, git repos also.
There we go. So I can do a
kubectl get repos.
I think it's git repos.
Or I think there also should be a
cluster. And then in all namespaces, you can
see, yep, there is this one git repository.
So you it's in the end Kubernetes resources
that you can create in any cluster.
So my provisioning step for launching a new
Kubernetes cluster with Fleet is to deploy the
Fleet operator,
add the CRDs to find my repositories,
and just let it let it do the
same. That's great. In the end, the UI
is nice and fine, but you probably will
not click this together but have if you
manage thousands of classes also have kind of
like a pipeline for that and automation for
that.
Excellent. I like it. It's very cool.
I think there's been a an awful lot
to take in here today, but like I
said, I'm very impressed by what we've seen.
I'm gonna check one thing before we finish
up, and that's the size of that cluster
to see if anyone that take me up
on the offer to add the fourth note.
I'll be disappointed if no one did it.
Where's
my note? You can on the notes in
the top.
No fourth notes.
I gave you a cube conflict publicly as
well.
Maybe it was too fast.
Oh, well.
That's great, Bastian. Is there anything you wanna
cover before we wrap up for today?
I would say, maybe let's have a look
at the questions if there was something else.
Yep. If there are any more questions, you've
got a minute to drop them in and
then we will wrap up for today's session.
Otherwise, it was what I wanted to show.
Yeah. We we covered a lot. Like, that's
an hour and fifteen minutes. We've covered, you
know, provision
in a k c s cluster with a
single command and under thirty seconds, which I'm
still mentally impressed with. We covered the deployment
of Rancher
to that cluster. We then spun up more
Kubernetes. The KCS clusters, one h e, one
not h e. Again, by tweaking it with
a couple of environment variables, which again ridiculously
easy. We brought them under management with Rancher
through one command, a cube CTL command and
a curl command.
And then we managed miraculously
all of us in an hour to deploy
Fleet and
deployment get all these workflows to all of
my clusters through labels. Like
yeah. It's a nice setup. I can see
the the appeal here. I can see why
people would want this.
Yeah. I also talked a lot about of
these of these edge use cases.
That makes complete sense to use something like
this because otherwise, it will just not scale
and work. But even if you have two,
three clusters or even if you have one
cluster, it would be also, this GitOps based
workflow can be very nice
to roll out your applications to staging and
production, for example.
Oh, yeah. Definitely. I can definitely see that.
I I I mean, I don't wanna rope
you in because we're, you know, on a
livestream and stuff and have you commit to
something, but I will. As I I definitely
think there's a lot of room here for
another session where we can dive into some
of the RBAC stuff. I mean, that's an
occasion things that we provide here. I think
it would be really cool to do a
deeper dive into that configure. But I won't
make you see a guest on the stream,
but I will chase you up afterwards.
Looking forward to it. Alright. Well, thank you
very much for joining me today. I think
that's a fantastic introduction to three different projects
there. I love what I see, and I'm
hoping I get to play with us more
in the future. So thank you very much
again, Sebastian. I hope the people have watched
and tuned in have enjoyed this. And I
will be back again soon. Thank you. Thank
you for having me. My pleasure. Thanks.